GREG PATERYN GOT A PIECE OF IT.
VEZINATING THE RELEASE POINT.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL SHOT ICING, ASD
OUT. BEST GAMES OF
THE SEASON AGAINST THE AVALANCHE
THE OTHER NIGHT.
COVID.TENDS TO .
WE ARE UNDERWAY INTING LAND TO S
ON NET, SO HE THROWS IT INTO THE
MIDDLE. THE POINT THE POINT.
BACK IN.
THIS IS KUCHEROV.
GO N NEXEXTT
COCOUPUPLELE O OF F MIMINUNUTET.
1111-2-2-1-1..
THTHATAT I IS S A A TRTREMEMENEG
1010-1-122 S SECECONONDSDS O OF.
THTHATAT'S'S H HUGUGE.E.MEME L K
DEDEFLFLECECTSTS O OFFFF - ---OE
NINIGHGHT.T.
>>>> T THEHERERE
DEDEFLFLECECTETED D OUOUT T OFO!
ININ
BABACKCK T TOO
YOYOU U CACANN I INTNTO O THTHEE
ANANAHAHEIEIMM Z ZONONE.E. O OFF
THTHEE R RIGIGHTHT C CIRIRCLCLE.
NENEEDED
KIKICKCK T THIHINGNG A A
GRGRANANTT H HASAS A AN N EVEVE.